>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" HAPPY
MONDAY IF YOU CAN CALL IT THAT
BUT YOU CAN'T LIKE MOST
AMERICANS ARE PROBABLY STILL
TRYING TO DIGEST WHAT IS
HAPPENING OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS.
AS WE THING ABOUT HOW CLOSE WE
CAME TO LOSING OUR DEMOCRACY.
LAST THURSDAY IT WAS JUNE 16TH A
DAY FOREVER BRANDED IN OUR
MEMORY A DAY THAT IS JOINED THE
PANTHEON OF TRAGIC TURNING
POINTS IN HUMAN HISTORY.
WHERE ARE YOU ON SIX, 16 AND
NEITHER WILL WE.
AT THE TIME THEY ARE PREPARING A
SHOW AND TONY FAUCI HAS PUSHED
FOR ANOTHER FOR KIDS.
SEEMS SO TRIVIAL NOW AS WE WERE
SPEAKING ON AIR AT THAT VERY
MOMENT A TEAM OF SEVEN SABOTEURS
HAD ENTERED THE CAPITAL GROUNDS
AND THEN PROCEEDED TO SABOTEURS
DO TO BREACH THE CAPITAL ITSELF.
INSIDE THOSE HOLLOW GROUNDS
WITHIN THE VERY WOMB OF
DEMOCRACY THESE RECORDS BEGAN
THEIR HUNT FOR STANDING MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS.
THAT HAPPENED LADIES AND SHOWMAN
IT SOUNDS SHOCKING TO YOU IT
GETS WORSE FROM THERE.
THIS IS NOT SOME SPONTANEOUS
OUTBREAK OF INSURRECTION, NO.
THIS WAS A METICULOUSLY PLANNED
COUP FROM AFAR.
THE GROUP IN THE CAPITAL WAS
UNDER DIRECT CONTROL OF AN
EXTREME CALLED STEPHEN COLBERT
DEFINITION IS A WHITE EXTREMIST.
THIS WHITE EXTREMIST
STEPHEN COLBERT HAD A PLACE IN
THE CAPITAL TO HELP THEM PULL
OFF HIS DIABOLICAL PLAN.
HE HAD MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
HIS EMPLOYMENT.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO BELIEVE
IT OR NOT HELPED THE
INSURRECTION ENTER THE CAPITAL.
JUST OPEN THE DOORS AND LET THEM
WALK IN.
YES THAT CAN HAPPEN.
STEPHANIE MURPHY OF FLORIDA, AND
A NEW MEMBER CALLED JAKE OF
MASSACHUSETTS.
BESMIRCHING HIS FAMILY NAME.
THOSE THREE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ALLOWED THE THE RECORDS AND
SOLID SIDE THE OFFICE WHILE
INSIDE THE INSURRECTIONIST TRY
TO GAIN ACCESS TO A RESTRICTED
AREA.
THERE WERE BOARDED BY BRAVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ARRIVE.
RISKING THEIR VERY LIVES TO
REMOVE THE INSURRECTIONIST FROM
THE PREMISES, BUT IT WAS NOT
ENOUGH.
HOURS LATER AN AIDE TO
CONGRESSMAN SECRETLY PERMITTED
THE INSURRECTIONIST TO READ
ENTER THE CAPITAL COMPLEX AND
THEN AT 8:30 P.M. THEY DID SOME
KIND OF DISTURBANCE.
ACCORDING TO ONE REPORT THEY
WERE BANGING ON WINDOWS INSIDE
THE CAPITAL AND TRASHED THE
PLACE.
COMMITTING VIOLENCE AGAINST OUR
DEMOCRACY.
FOR THAT APPARENTLY WE ARE
HEARING TONIGHT THEY WERE PUT IN
JAIL.
WITHIN HOURS THEY WERE OUT
AGAIN.
NOW THE MAN WHO CONTROLS THIS
ATTEMPT, STEPHEN COLBERT KNEW
EXACTLY WHAT HE WAS DOING.
HE KNEW THE STAKES, HE KNEW THE
CRIMES THAT HE WAS COMMITTING.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE JUST LAST
YEAR THIS WHITE EXTREMIST
STEPHEN COLBERT EXPLAINED IT
GROWN MEN WHO MEMBERS OF CONGREE
NOT PRANKSTERS, NOT PROTESTERS,
THEY ARE DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
>> LORD HAVE MERCY THERE ARE
SOME TOP DARK SUBJECTS THAT WE
TALK ABOUT ON THE SHOW
OCCASIONALLY, BUT I'VE REALLY
BEEN UPSET AS I HAVE BEEN
TONIGHT.
THIS THE MOST SHOCKING AND LEAST
SURPRISING THING I'VE EVER SEEN
AND HIS FOLLOWERS DID EXACTLY
WHAT THEY TOLD HIM TO DO.
BEHAVE IN A WAY THAT'S WHAT'S
THE WORD?
DEPLORABLE.
ONE OF THESE DOMESTIC TERRORISTS
EVEN BROKE INTO SPEAKER PELOSI'S
OFFICE.
THEY LIVE IN AN ALTERNATE
UNIVERSE THAT IS NOW COLLAPSING
IN ON ITSELF IT'S LIKE A BLACK
HOLE OF WHITENESS.
AND THIS WAS NEVER SOME KIND OF
PEACEFUL PROTEST THIS WAS
CHARLOTTESVILLE COME HOME TO
ROOST.
>> Tucker: IT IS SHOCKING IS
OUR DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
STEPHEN COLBERT AND WHAT THE
COMMUNITY CALLS FORESHADOWING
DESCRIBED HIS OWN COUP.
AND YET STEPHEN COLBERT SOMEHOW
STILL HAS ACCESS TO THE AIRWAVES
AND TO DIGITAL MEDIA.
SPREADING HIS HATE ON FEATHERED.
CONVINCING FUTURE GENERATIONS
THAT INSURRECTION'S TO DO WHAT
HIS TEAM OF DID LAST WEEK.
THAT MUST STOP.
PEOPLE WHO PLAN COOS MUST BE
SILENCED THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR
THAT AND ANYONE WHO DISAGREES
SHOULD BE DISCONNECTED FROM
AMAZON WEB SERVICES IMMEDIATELY.
NO SPREADING HATE.
STOPPING WHITE EXTREMIST
STEPHEN COLBERT FROM PASSING ON
HIS MESSAGE OF INSURRECTION OF
THE COUNTRY WON'T SOLVE FOR THE
REST OF US ARE LIVING WITH AND
THAT IS TRAUMA.
AND LIKE ALL TRAUMA JOURNALISTS
ARE AFFECTED MOST PROFOUNDLY.
WE ARE SCARRED BY WHAT WE SAW.
IT'LL BE A LONG TIME BEFORE WE
CAN REVISIT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
BEFORE WE CAN FORGET WHAT WE
WERE DEMOCRACY SHOOK ON ITS VERY
FOUNDATION.
TO TAKE THERAPY AND A LOT OF
SUPPORT FROM OUR FELLOW
SURVIVORS BEFORE WE CAN
RECAPTURE THE CAREFREE INNOCENCE
THAT STEPHEN COLBERT STOLE FROM
US BEFORE WE CAN FEEL SAFE
AGAIN.
WE ARE NOT ALONE IN OUR
DISPARAGING.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE ONE OF
AMERICA'S DARKEST DAYS.
>> BECAME ONE OF THE DARKEST
DAYS AND POLITICAL HISTORY.
>> ONE OF THE DARKEST DAYS IN
THIS NATION'S HISTORY.
>> ONE OF MOST DRAMATIC AND DARK
DAYS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> ONE OF THE DARKEST DAYS IN
U.S. HISTORY.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE DARKEST
DAYS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> WHAT DARK BOTTLE OF BOURBON
TO DRINK?
>> Tucker: PEOPLE FEEL THE
STUFF DEEPLY.
YOU JUST ROBOTS A NERD HARD AND
CALLOUSED TO THE NEWS.
YOU DON'T FEEL COME BUT WE DO.
WE DO FEEL.
YOU SEE SOMEONE LIKE THAT SCENE
INSURRECTION TAKE PLACE BEFORE
YOUR VERY EYES AND IT HURTS YOU.
IT CHANGES YOU'RE NOT THE SAME
PERSON HOW LONG WILL TAKE TO
HEAL?
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW.
CNN JUST INTERVIEWED A
ROLLING STONE AFTER YEAR AND A
HALF OF THE LAST INSURRECTION
STILL HASN'T HEALED.
WATCH.
>> LAST FOR YEARS HE SAID
SOMETIMES I'M FINE SOMETIMES I
WANT TO STOP FOR HOURS AND
SOMETIMES I JUST WANT TO SLEEP.
THAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE TRAUMA
THAT SOUNDS LIKE PTSD.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU STILL
EXPERIENCE THAT?
>> I DO THINK SO TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT.
>> THIS MORNING FOR I CAME DOWN
HERE I WAS AGAIN AT THE CAPITAL.
NO MY RECENTLY CAME DOWN TO
VISIT ME AND I MEMBER THINKING
TO MYSELF MAN, I CAN'T WAIT
UNTIL I CAN LOOK AT THIS AND NOT
FEEL SAD.
>> Tucker: YOU LOOK AT SUMMING
LIKE THAT AND YOU'RE TEMPTED TO
DISMISS IT OUT OF HAND.
YOU'RE HAVING TROUBLE SLEEPING
SOB FOR NO REASON THAT'S BECAUSE
YOU'VE A BARREN PERSONAL LIFE.
YOUR CELEBRATE YOUR ONLY
MEANINGFUL IF HUMAN CONTACT
COMES FROM THE UBER EATS GUY.
YOU LIVE OUT YOUR EMOTIONAL LIFE
ON NETFLIX, THAT IS YOUR CORE
PROBLEM I COULDN'T REALLY BE IN
INSURRECTION.
EXCUSE ME SORRY.
OR DISRUPTED YOUR SLEEP.
BUT IT CAN.
FOR JOURNALISTS, THE STUFF
HURTS.
IF YOU THINK IT'S BAD FOR US IN
THE NEWS MEDIA?
WHAT YOU THINK IT WAS LIKE FOR
THE LAWMAKERS WHO ARE TRAPPED
INSIDE THURSDAY NIGHT?
IN THE LAST INSURRECTION EVEN
NOTICED SHE WAS NOWHERE NEAR THE
CAPITAL, PROBABLY GETTING HER
NAILS DONE BUT IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
SANDY CORTEZ NEARLY DIED.
>> SHE IS GIVEN A HARROWING
ACCOUNT OF HER EXPERIENCE ON
JANUARY 6.
>> IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
HARROWING ACCOUNTS SO FAR.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN TELL THAT
HARROWING STORY.
>> THE HARROWING STORY OF HOW
SHE HAD FROM ATTACKERS DURING
THE CAPITOL RIOTS.
>> BOOM, BOOM, BOOM.
BOOM BOOM.
>> Tucker: THAT IS WHAT
INSURRECTION LOOKS LIKE.
THERE IS NO CHARADE LIKE MIMING
I CAN EVER FULLY EXPRESS THE
PAIN INSIDE.
WE ARE GONNA DEAL WITH THAT OUR
QUIET ALONE TIME POSSIBLY
WEARING UPSCALE TURTLENECKS WE
WILL LET YOU KNOW.
THE QUESTION IS ONCE WE HAVE HAD
AN ACTIVE WAR LIKE THIS HOW DOES
THE COUNTRY RESPOND?
HOW DO WE ALL RESPOND?
BOOM, BOOM, BOOM AS SANDY WOULD
SAY.
A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION ONE
UNDERWAY BY THE WAY IN A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
LET THE MEMORY DIE SO WHO'S
GONNA LEAVE THIS?
WILL THE OBVIOUS CANDIDATE IS
LIZ CHENEY.
SPEAK OF CRIME ADAM KINZINGER.
THEY ARE NATURALS.
WE CALLED THEM TO SEE HOW
THEY'RE PLANNING AND TRYING TO
COMMEMORATE THIS DAY WE GOT BACK
TO US YET PROBABLY SLEEPING OR
WEEPING.
BUT WE CAN ASSUME FROM PAST
EXPERIENCES THAT HE FEELS THIS
REALLY DEEPLY REALLY DEEPLY
WATCH.
>> INSIDE WHAT THE IMPACT OF
THAT DAY.
DEMOCRACIES ARE NOT DEFINED BY
OUR BAD DAYS.
>> Tucker: HE IS RIGHT AND
WE'VE MADE FUN OF THEM IN THE
PAST LIKE A GROWN DUDE CRYING ON
TV REMARKED THAT WE APOLOGIZED.
WE CAN'T RECOVER.
THIS REALLY ONLY ONE OTHER PATH
FOR RECOVERING IF YOU TALK TO
ANY RECOVERY EXPERT THEY WILL
TELL YOU THAT THE WAY TO RECOVER
IS HE VICIOUSLY PUNISH THE
PEOPLE WHO HURT YOUR FEELINGS.
STEP ONE.
IT'S ALWAYS STEP ONE.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO KNEED
OUT SOME PD STURDY PUNISHMENTS
THEY BEEN JAILED FOR ONE NIGHT.
THE PENALTY FOR INSURRECTION IS
DEATH BROCK LONG FOR THAT HERE.
THIS IS THE MODERATE SHOW.
AS OUR FELLOW AMERICANS WE OWE
THEM A SECOND CHANCE THANKFULLY
THERE'S RECENT PRESIDENTS